from the University of Minnesota because
those things are constraints and things
like that he's gonna tell us about
problems of robust high dimensional
statistics thank you thanks about the
organizer especially in Lea's it's very
great pleasure to be here actually my
first time here I was actually very
ambitious before I'm going to planning
to tell you about nothing to tell about
many problems of robust high dimensional
statistics but mainly on one problem and
the issue will be on robustness not so
much on the high dimension also let me
mention it's a joint work with Tyler
mano I'll actually mention all the
credits at the end but it's important to
say that we all the new results here are
joint if Tyler and Tyler actually led
the work so it's sort of a showcase for
Tyler is now at MIT and for telling you
where I'm going to probably I should
tell you where I'm coming from
and this is actually relevant to a lot
of other talks but even though I don't
have much time I think it's important to
mention it
so robustness has you know has very long
history that actually goes back to Adam
and Eve I'm not going to tell you about
the times of Adam and Eve but I'll tell
you about the times of people who
challenged the theory of Adam and Eve
and we'll go to back to Galileo so if
you go back and look at the science and
even science today
most scientists know to kind of things
about robustness so if they are kind of
advanced mathematically but you know
that you don't need to use leaf squares
but you need to use least absolute
deviation and I think the audience here
is well familiar about least absolute
deviation line versus least squares line
but maybe you don't know the long
history and as I said it already goes
back to Galileo Galilei the other
example is very simple idea of rejection
of outliers
okay so even if you don't societies you
don't know much about mathematics we
know they have to reject outliers and in
terms of quantitative history I could
list the following people and it's
interesting to see
surely that it is sort of American
topics about two Americans from the 19th
century and Evan and Scott write a paper
about it actually he mentioned position
American topic but uh you know being
even actually at Berkeley Utley the
campus of Berkeley it may be the best
place to talk about Great America but I
have to say comment you know looking at
the diversity of the speaker here and
the next slide this is not the kind of
America kind of wall that would like to
make great again so okay so so so this
is about history of robustness very
early history then comes with fury of
robustness which start at the 1960 and
actually in the morning stalkers already
some review about it and when people
think about the robustness people think
about Huber we define robustness very
well in terms of insensitivity to small
deviation from the assumptions which
made a lot of sense when he started
working on robustness and most models
were of Gaussian distributions and he
actually talks about two works which
were in were influential to him so one
of them actually we heard about this
morning the work of Tookie we started
some mathematical analysis that are
later resulted in the minimax analysis
of Huber which he also heard about this
morning the other influential work is a
by enscombe about rejection of outliers
where he talks about the idea of the
pairing in front for insurance policy if
you want to deal with outliers and it
has a very natural trade-off with
performance
what is interesting if you read one of
the assumptions he talks about having to
ignore computational cost and this was
in 1960 it's interesting to see that all
of these people had very strong effect
on computation nowadays but in the 1960
verdiant and when they had to analyze
robustness within care about computation
according to Huber actually the the
credit for the effect of computation on
robustness it goes to big
so why do I actually do this kind of
introduction because I really think you
know these kind of ideas actually are
rooted with very basic ideas coming from
science which I reviewed before and this
is about foundation of data science so
we have to really care about the basic
ideas with the data scientists care
about before we develop theory for it
they're also very nice ideas of
presentation both in writing and both in
talks but we should probably follow
there's a nice emphasis on computation
but computation cannot be any polynomial
time algorithm it has to be reasonable
computation and there are many other
aspects coming from statistics it's not
that just robust to outliers you know if
you have some assumption on your model
you have to be very flexible when you
change your model the model of a inliers
you have to consider other aspect for
example causality which was actually
discussed there this morning so so
keeping all these things in mind I would
like to move on and talk about one
problem but I know quite well about
which is robust a stress recovery and I
think it's very natural so I want to
review it and give you some insight and
then I talk about new result for the
adversarial case and I think most people
here actually care about the adversarial
case of outliers and I was actually
ambitious and thought I can also talk
about related problem but it probably
has to be avoided ok so what is the
robust hospice recovery problem so
mathematically it's very simple so we
can think of this cartoon and we have in
Liars coming from a given subspace they
can either be exactly understand space
all around this subspace so my enlarged
of axes here and outliers which are
presented here by red circles and they
come from a different distributions
possibly away from this subspace so
someone is giving you this data and ask
you to find the hidden subspace
so this is what we call a bus a Swiss
recovery and questions about it
okay so seems simple so why should we
care about this problem so this is the
foundation of data science so what do
data scientists care about they care
about PCA okay and PCA in terms of size
pieces we all know that it's actually
you know it gives us the subspaces
minimize the following least squares
energy and we all know why PCI is is
great you know it's a very basic generic
tool if I give you a data in high
dimensions of noise is amplified in high
dimensions I reduce the dimension with
PCA it has very nice properties and then
it is actually it's able to somewhat
denote the data so I can do you know I
can successfully do different tasks in
the low dimension for example cluster of
these data okay so it's a very useful
generic tool the one with PCA but it's
not robust to outliers so in this
cartoon we have a points on this line
and the PCA lines find another and you
know it's different than very hidden
line here so the goal of a robust
recovery is kind of to develop
alternative to PCA which is robust to
outliers but also has been nice
properties of PCI for example we
attracted computational power
so actually there are three main
approaches to robust address recovery
and these are sober you know these
approaches are so basic that we have
seen them in previous talk so one
approach is we just to search
exhaustively for this subspace and
people had this similar approach in
previous top I call it brute-force
search the other approach is to reject
outliers or filter outlier so we have
very interesting filtering algorithms in
previous talks and then this idea of
energy minimization and the different
kinds of energy so one simple energy is
the least absolute deviation energy so
before I told you that PCA has the
square here and now we've got the square
and half lives if we try to minimize
this list absolute deviation but there
are many other important metrics so you
know everything seems very simple and no
one asked me questions so far but
actually I tricked you a little bit so
this formulation of RS r is not
well-defined in general what I mean so I
can create a data of enlarged and
outliers where innards are on the line
and outliers are away from the line but
it sank but there is no really
underlying suspects in the data we
cannot agree with with a unique one for
example you know they the most trivial
case if all my enlarged at the origin
are no outliers then any any line here
will be okay so a problem is not
well-defined
of course I can you know I can
generalize this case and have inliers
actually concentrated on a low
dimensional subspace and now if the
outliers also happen to be in another
subspace it's possible that someone will
output another subspace not the one I
actually originally meant to have so we
need to have some general principle
which you can actually express
mathematically in different ways and
also see it in other ways of works
actually will you to reviewed in a
previous talks or mainly yesterday but
in layers must permeate
L star so we cannot concentrate on low
dimensional subspaces of the underlying
subspace we also need to respect the
outliers of the most extreme example
when the outliers are on a line and then
in this case you know we can associate
this line in this case only have
underlined line this we can think this
is the main line or we can take part of
the outliers here and part of the in
Lars and have another subspace so it
actually gives rise to be another
principle of restriction of alignment of
outliers there are other examples I
won't get into member many example
exactly it's a more complicated notion
but in this particular example that I
talked before you you see a very some
interplay between the two principles I
also I want to have the in large
permeate further or subspace but I also
don't want the outliers to concentrate
on a lower dimensional subspace so one
more clarification is that for
simplicity assume that L star is a
linear subspace otherwise they have
another parameter and a family become
more complicated I also want to clarify
that it kind of inherently non convex
formulation so whatever method you have
you have to recall that after all you
are looking for a subspace which belongs
to a set of all the dimension of
subspaces in our D that is the gross
Manian and this verse Manion is a non
convex set so actually you are searching
in a non convex set so whatever you're
going whatever you're going to do is
going to be inheritant ly non convex
even if you convex if I it important
problem for practitioners like this
scale is very important so you know I
can give you this cartoon and I have to
sorry say they have this line and that
line and I can compute the error with
respect to this line and arrow with
respect to that line and see that I have
a very large error with respect to that
line so maybe this is the line they
describe the data but if I also take
into account the scale with respect to
the origin I see that this might be an
outlier and we need to reject it
it's something we need to keep in mind
and there are methods which are
scale-invariant in the sensors that do
not weigh the magnitude of a data point
actually we all know maybe you don't
recall right now there are any method
can be scale invariant how do you make
any method scale invariant so you just
you know you have your data you scale it
to the sphere like you divide each point
here by the norm of the point okay so
now with respect to the origin the
points are on a circle and now okay so
now we scan the data to the sphere and
now we apply the method I say we all
know it because practitioners in data
science know that before we apply PCA
they better scan the data to the sphere
so it's called spherical PCA okay so
this is very very common and just it's
just a comment that as long as you know
in our setting of linear subspaces we
can scale the dare to the sphere and
have scaling variant methods slope
comment is but you know there are
instances were scanning data to the
sphere actually makes a famine Wars here
you have lines of inliers and few
outlets at the origin but when scale
clings to the sphere outliers actually
become worse but this is one pathologic
example
it's now this is the foundation a
workshop and the question is what can
theoretically setting exist for robust
hospice recovery so one setting people
here care about this adversarial
outliers but as I told you young okay so
I had my original assumption but the
suspects is linear so I take into
account the center III remove that
assumption of centering the data but
there is Rick so it currently for our
theoretical analysis okay you have you
can then talk about the case of a fine
subspaces and you have an extra
parameter you also need to evaluate it
and you also know some methods about
symmetry ization but actually sometimes
are relevant here also okay so any other
questions before I move on yeah
[Music]
so I'm not sure I'm following you let's
see I will give you some models more
specific models and see if they're
satisfying to you or not okay okay so
the case of adversarial outliers but I
would have told you about the town can
be ill-defined in general right so we
need to make sure that the inliers are
permeated in some sense we also need to
you know we don't restrict anything
about the way the outliers looks like
but we need to respect the fraction of
outliers otherwise we cannot solve a
problem so we need some bound on a
fraction of outliers an upper bound or a
lower boundary on a fraction of inliers
I usually like to have the lower bound
on the fraction of inliers fair outliers
which they called snr so I think of a
enlarge as a hidden signal or the
specific hidden signal and the outliers
is noise okay so so setting of address
any anything that you have on out
outliers but you have restriction a
lower bound of the SNR and you have
permeated in lies in some sense one
common important comment we have to
formulate it for scale-invariant
algorithms because otherwise the other
algorithms have some restriction on the
magnitude and they cannot deal with any
outliers
okay so this is one one example now
people also talk about statistical
models with reason why they want
statistical models because in practice
you know here you have to restrict the
fraction of outliers but there are data
set would have a lot of corruptions we
have many many outliers but they have
some more assumptions on the way the
outliers are generated so that's why you
have to deal with different statistical
models that allow you high corruption or
low SNR
now another strange model actually very
official model but actually it turns out
to be very very interesting in theory is
of enlarged and outliers in general
position and I'm taking the definition
from a paper by heart heart and Moira
well they say that actually maybe let me
make sure you're all with me so when I
say capital D is the ambient dimension
and little D is the intrinsic dimension
the subspace okay so any set of capital
D points are linearly linearly
independent unless it includes at least
bit less one points from L star so in
some sense L star is the only sub space
in your data like everything else is
very independent with respect to it the
outliers are very independent not just
if I do of course if I take only
outliers are independent but also if I
take only few inliers will be
independent so what why is it important
so they have a very interesting result
that says that for general not not just
for viscous in general if your SNR
fraction of enlarged per outliers is
less than the intrinsic dimension over
the differences of a dimension or the
dimension of the orthogonal complement
of the subspace then the problem is
small set expansion hard and then they
want to see that we actually can still
get above this snr so they use this
particular mode that model and show that
they can actually exactly recover the
subspace with certain algorithms they
showing also other people with follow
the walk show Tanjong in their various
castro in
so it is very interesting in in terms of
the theoretical aspect of the hardness
safe threshold but it's not a real model
for applications so I would rather
concentrate on these two models always
information to be possible so is the
problem always in identifying are there
any information to predict limits in
terms of what because so they tell you
no but if you assume you know in general
SNR cannot build less than this but I
can have specific models where I can
have lower is enough right if I if I
have Gaussian in Lars and Gaussian
outliers I can actually I can take this
and us 2 goes to 0 because it's really
easy to see the line or the subspace so
this particular model is always the was
always oh oh so what you ask me asking
me about the GP model right so so so I
know I know for sure you know so I know
they have visit but I don't know if in
this particular model you can go down
not sure I know I know that they did it
for the general case I have to go back
to the paper and I can't answer you this
grand your GP can you just take little D
plus 1 points and until you find them at
a really deep header and then say the
subspace they span is the okay so it
does not meet for make a few yeah yeah
okay sorry
so I need us any question you ask about
just the information here and not about
the computation ability yeah so this is
true so it's enough to what once you
have D plus 1 points information
theoretical it's enough ok I
misunderstood your question
very good thanks for clarifying okay
and actually we will get back to it okay
so so what method have been done for the
serial outliers so at least in the
subspace recovery the most kind of
[Music]
likeable method is outlier pursuit
which has pretty big snr so you have a
big constant times little deviant
missing dimension times a incoherence
part parameter so with actually I'm not
going to define it here because it's not
a natural parameter for b7 it's very
natural for compressed sensing it's
natural for the low rank plus 4 plus
sparse setting but I don't think in this
geometric setting is a natural parameter
but it can be pretty large too I just
tell you that it's kind of inversely
proportional to the permeance of the
data so it's kind of a way to measure
the inverse permeance
of the data there is even a slightly
bigger constant with another algorithm
and then there have been some exciting
ideas but not for this problem but I
still mention them here if you know one
of them for example is for detecting
Gaussian which you can also talk about
the Gaussian on a subspace but it's
actually for for a very different
setting so now let's ask you know
several questions regarding this
studying and one of them is the question
that you just asked me so so so what are
the question one is what is the lowest
snr with well-defined setting or as you
can call it the information setting
the other thing is is very hardness
result for Lois SNR which were they kind
of talked about but in you know how it
plays in this setting and what is the
lowest lowest SN out obtained by
reasonable time algorithm for exact
Southwest recovery and you know all this
is kind of very theoretical setting but
I want you to see an algorithm which is
actually very competitive but it works
not just for very clean setting but also
when I have the little bit of noise and
when I have any has some flexibility to
other other models okay so we call our
initial setting and as I said before but
with problem is generally ill-defined so
so so you know and and the question is
first to understand we you know
information limits so what is the
smallest in case of a dresser outlets
what is the smallest SNR so shook our
minds and Manoa claimed its order of D
and we gave an example we're actually on
each line of a subspace you have some in
layers but it's a problematic example
because you know the in-laws are not
permeated throughout the whole subspace
okay so so the reason why they got we're
all order of D is not because of
information limit and indeed if you
assume a case of permeated in layers for
example you assume a different notion of
general position only for the in large
that any D points in L star stand L star
okay then you conceive it for the
adversarial case you have the
well-defined setting if a number of in
Lars is almost bigger than where when
half of the point okay so you have about
fifty percent more than about fifty
percent in liars or SNR of order one at
least order one so this is for the case
of general position in large but
anything about the outliers if you also
have general position outliers but I
slightly defined it different event
before I can show you that
and actually already gave us approve the
problem is well-defined with the number
of enlarged is bigger than little D and
now you can have very very small SNR
when n goes to infinity okay so now the
question is computationally what are the
limits so we already know I already
mentioned to your result that tells you
that you cannot have any small SNR so
all right then multiple tells us that
this is the bound of an SNR but so you
know so we know that it's too small you
know way too small as and now that we
talked about before has a limit you know
we can't go and any small SNR but
actually the result is also relevant for
the adversary case where I told you I
have order of one SNR in theory because
what happens here if you have very high
dimension of of little D so D minus D is
one or order of one so if you compute
the threshold that way give little the
over one order one you get order of D or
order of capital D because you can't go
below it and this is why why I think you
see in kahramana so the order of the
fact or not because of the example that
we give you so now the question is
whether we can actually obtain this
fraction right by eight by an algorithm
we saw the algorithm of sugar Armani
Sandman or where you get such you know
constant time little D but maybe you can
get smaller constant so before I move on
any questions about it okay so I'm going
to give you an algorithm that will prove
the point but actually you can get a
constant like this I it's not a
practical algorithm so I don't want to
spend too much time and if you need to
tell you know if you have short
attention and you need the break four
minutes or you don't need to follow but
but then get back with more
concentration so
so what is the best SNR for that one can
get or one of the you know yeah so
bestest enough that we can get is with a
brute force force search which is called
by electric engineer Rancic type
algorithm so they do it's very simple
you know we take random subset of X
which spans at this subspace okay and
now we check you know we take the span
of these points so now we get a subspace
we span of this point now we take the
number of points that have angle less
with L less than a certain consensus
parameter so you can even take in the
clean cased out to be zero and just
count the number on the subspace okay
and once you are bigger than you know
you have more points than a certain
parameter little m which will be half of
the number of points you're fine and you
output L start but it's possible that
the number of iteration you know already
passed and you didn't find this out
specially just output will suspect which
the largest number one so it's a very
simple
Rancic algorithm so what we can show for
this it's first of all you know if the
SN now is bigger than one and you take
you you run it sufficiently from many
number of iterations and you have
sufficiently small parameter tau and
your parameter M the consensus parameter
of counting the number of points on the
South space is bigger than half of the
points you can just take it to be half
of the points when L star is recovered
with high probability but you can have
exponential time but if you restrict
version are to be bigger equal than C
times little D so L star is recovered
with high probability and it's enough to
take the number of iterations to be
order of 1 so the complexity is order of
a number of points times V number the
ambient dimension turns me into music
dimension
so the main issue now is to come up with
the more really robust algorithm in the
sense that if we you know it's a it's
robust to ever setting not just to this
very artificial setting of adversary
outliers but before I move are just kind
of mention what want small issues which
actually I cannot resolve so what we
noticed is that especially when we
enlarge D we can take C to be less than
1 and if you notice actually we the
threshold by heart and mode fact we said
that C has to be 1 when little V is
equal capital D minus 1 so we can take
windey goes to infinity we can take C 2
goes to you know C can be any positive
number so something goes wrong in terms
of what happens with their hardness of
computation threshold and I'm not sure
what's going going wrong but it's
something I'll be happy to discuss with
people here and I actually had err we
check our argument which is very simple
so I'm sure we have C which can be less
than 1 okay but but let me focus on one
kind of the more interesting algorithm
and I want to decide present' something
which is more robust to other setting
not just to the very specific setting of
adversarial outliers but it also works
well for adversarial outliers so let me
show you what you get and somehow
compare it with the common algorithm of
Xu comma or Amanda Sandman or so in
order to follow what we we have I need
to review what I call the well-tempered
landscape of this energy function and
the geodesic gradient descent algorithm
to
to optimize the this energy function
okay so so what I mean by well-tempered
landscape so you know one thing you have
to keep in mind is that this gives rise
to non convex optimization so again this
energy look it as a function it's a nice
convex function but we actually minimize
it over adverse Manion the set of all
surfaces which is not convex okay so we
have a non convex optimization which may
have many local minima you know PCA is
also non convex optimization but there
is something very interesting that
happens in terms of local minima the
same as the global minima so this is not
the case here but under certain
conditions the energy landscape behaves
very well so okay thank you so just to
exemplify it let's take this cartoon of
data which was generated generated from
a certain statistical model so we have
points on the line we only have six
points on this line and we have outliers
and now we want to see how this energy
behaves like so we identify know where
the surfaces are just lines through the
origin so we identify them with the
angles they make with the x-axis
okay so this line the x-axis itself is
either you know the angle 0 of an angle
1 angle PI I just divide the angles by
type so this is the same this line is we
you know has the angle PI over 2 or 1/2
here which is the global minimum of this
energy and now we notice that there is a
neighborhood around this line where the
energy landscape behaves very nicely so
there is a nice you know streak decrease
of the cost function towards the global
minimum outside this neighborhood we can
have different local minima in the in
the neighborhood things are nice it's
possible that you know things are not
differentiable but some but the sub
differential is still negative
so we have a result which says that you
know this works in general there is a
certain stability condition that under
which you have this water called well
temper landscape now you can also show
that in this neighborhood under this
condition the ethic gradient descent
algorithm for this energy function will
converge sufficiently fast to the
southwest L star and under a similar
condition you can actually initialize by
GCA in this neighbor so it's a very
simple algorithm we just you start with
PCA and then you run your data gradient
descent and then you converge to the
surface l star and it will work if a
certain condition is satisfied so now I
want to check this stability condition
under the model of adversary adversarial
outliers so now what we have to keep in
mind that you're desecrating descent is
problematic for the serial outliers
because it's not scale invariant right
if you have you know the magnitude of
the points affect this energy but I told
you what one should do so we're going to
talk about spherical geodesic gradient
descent I'm going to spirits as my data
in the following way the baggage point
where the norm and this is the data
matrix will now denoted by X tilde and
then I will apply the GTD algorithm so
in order to to analyze the performance
of this algorithm I want to introduce a
very natural spherical condition number
of in layers so I take my data metrics
of inliers of the columns which are data
points are scaled to the sphere and
actually look so this is the covariance
the empirical covariance matrix of the
inliers and I take the largest eigen
value and divided by the thief
I can value and this is my condition
number so if my enlarge appear are
nicely permeated it's of order 1 with
this small eigen value is like this one
but if are not nicely permeated then I
have a big gap okay so it's actually
inversely proportional to the notion of
fermions and now the miracle is that the
stability condition for this algorithm
when I initialize it in in the
neighborhood of radius gamma is the
following one I need to I need to have
good initialization now usually I
initialize a PCI what's the result for
PCA is a result of PCA is that if lessor
now is bigger than this quantity then I
can NN I apply SVC a spherical PCA when
it will be in this neighborhood it won't
find exactly the suspects but it will be
in this neighborhood and now if I
combine the two together and choose the
right gamma it doesn't matter to me
which gamma I have it if my SNR is
bigger than this number then you know
when this number times little D times
the spherical condition number then I
have well term the landscape and then
the SDG D initialized with first pc i
will find my subspace if you want it to
be really really fast and have linear
convergence that I have to slightly
change my condition and have a following
thing which is not such a big change
and if you want to know something about
the spherical condition number so at
least you have as a traffic Gaussian
distribution of inliers this is the
order of the spherical condition number
just a constant it's not a large
constant unlike what you have in
chukerman is a menorah which actually
controls like log n so I have a quick
table of comparison I won't have time to
go through it but we have our s G GD and
you can compare it with the outlet
resultant torque which has bigger
constant and different kind of notion of
inverse permeance parameter unlike the
cutter here the other words not exactly
on this topic but I just mentioned them
here I don't have time to review them
they are not about exactly Cauvery of
subspace there is a result for the
spherical PC but it's not about exact
recovery just about approximation and
varies with runs the type algorithm
which is not a really practical
algorithm in general so maybe to say
something but you know the SVD is
practical it also works well with other
statistical models I don't have time to
do it here but if you check out paper on
the geodetic gradient descent you will
see that actually you know we have
different statistical models and and it
even adapt to different regimes of
samples so for example if you have
Gaussian in layers and Gaussian outliers
if the number of outlines is bigger than
some internal following threshold you
can actually deal for it forgiven s and
now you can deal with this snr so you
can actually take this and r 2 goes to 0
in this model and still deal with the
data so this is back to your question
but you you can you know it can happen
in some situations
and also under this model you have very
nice complexity for STD D so so it's
time to start summarizing so I'll just
mention that you know I didn't touch in
open directions in our start so for
example I didn't talk at all about noise
we have some result of p2 for small
perturbations to note the only few
results which shows that not nice
behavior to note but I don't have time
to review them here but I would really
like to see analysis for spiked model
which is actually missing but questions
about really large sample and high
dimensional limits especially in terms
of computation what happens with you you
know you can store your data on one
machine you want to work on a
distributed a machine or this with
network how do you estimate the surface
dimension so Edgar who is gonna seem
right on has very nice theoretical
result about estimation of subject
dimensions of PCA but I don't see how it
applies to process discover it will be
really interesting
clarification of it of Gredos will be
interesting case for applications I told
you it's kind of it's a version of PCA
but um I want I want to see you know
more evidence that it indeed improves
over PCA so I have few examples where I
know it can improve but in a lot of
cases that I saw the improvement is not
high enough so so or at least not as
high as spiracle PCA which is the choice
of many practical people so as I would
like to see a very careful study of
these the other thing which kind of
disturbs me you know we we kind of
advocate for gradient descent and
there's so many methods nowadays of
gradient descent and it's becoming maybe
intellectually boring so I would you
know I know we have other methods that
work even better in practice but we
don't have a nice fear of them and it
will be interesting to see how maybe
other make theory for other method which
are not where the end descent
and other specific issues there are many
other problems with the analysis I
talked about here is a very relevant to
but I I don't have time to talk about it
here I can discuss it with you later and
let me just give you few take-home
messages so buses poster cover is a very
basic problem
I think it's motivated from data science
and it raises interesting questions I
touched few of them but many open
questions and I gave you here a clean
treatment of the case of the adversary
or the serial outliers the led RS
optimization is non convex but still we
have a non convex algorithm with
guarantee that is shown to be fast and
flexible and the ideas that we have
developed here seems to extend to other
other problems I mentioned before I had
in the slide before but didn't have time
to talk about and actually no I
collaborated with a lot of people on
robust a specific ovary or low-rank
approximation and learned there from a
lot of collaborators but mainly in this
talk I highlighted the collaboration
with Vitale mano and as I said before
it's really in over new results it's
really showcase for a Tyler is now a
very
[Applause]
say you had adversarial outliers was the
adversary allowed to do when he produces
outliers you put them anywhere yeah you
can put them anywhere any size any
magnitude yeah and he can try to put
them all in a different subspace to
fully own it yeah the worst case is when
there are cars on their line in some
sense question so so you you talked
about convergence of a Romanian type
gradient method and and that seems like
it's assuming you know the correct
dimension of the subspace sure is that
that's true but okay so it's actually
this is too you know so so okay you get
so we have a general theorem but you
have if under certain condition
something happens when you have this you
know so if you you know under certain
condition very nice things happens but
in real situation you really need to
know the dimension of the surface so the
condition will kind of be realizable in
some sense you know if you really have
such base in the data it makes sense to
know whether mentioned so it's a good
point actually if you say you ran it
will say too high of a dimension as your
guest but it's still converging and
include the true subspaces
so so so so not necessarily so it's very
different than pca but you you know you
have kind of different components and
some sometimes you know you do something
in one dimension and you increase the
dimension or reduce it and the structure
is very different you know you don't you
don't have nested subspaces so so it's
very problematic and that's why it's
it's really hard actually to to have an
algorithm to find the dimension of the
all right let's think jagged odd and
there's a five-minute break ins in the
next talk